[Musica]
alla base della democrazia c'è la
conoscenza delle questioni che dobbiamo
ribattere per poter decidere
questo significa che se parliamo di
democrazia digitale
dobbiamo avere la conoscenza e la
consapevolezza di che cosa sia
innanzitutto la società digitale di
quali sono i meccanismi che la governano
enrico che cos'è la società digitale per
capire cos'è la società digitale è utile
fare un parallelo con la società
industriale che a partire dal 1700 fino
a tutto il 1900 ha soppiantato la
società agricola la società industriale
è stata basata su una automazione di
macchine che hanno soppiantato la forza
fisica dell'uomo
questa è stata una rivoluzione sul piano
tecnico appunto la produzione di oggetti
è stata resa più veloce è aumentata di
quantità ed è stata anche una
rivoluzione sul piano sociale perché
questa produzione di oggetti ha reso
possibile migliorare la qualità di vita
delle persone e dell'intera società
poi a metà del secolo scorso inizia una
nuova rivoluzione che assomiglia a
quella industriale
è la rivoluzione delle macchine digitali
macchine che elaborano rappresentazioni
elaborano segni all'inizio questa
rivoluzione sembra assomigliare a quella
che l'ha preceduta della rivoluzione
industriale
invece dopo un po di decenni ci si rende
conto che si tratta di qualcosa di
drammaticamente nuovo perché agisce su
un piano diverso agisce sul piano della
conoscenza
queste macchine digitali sono conoscenza
che può essere messa in azione action
hubble nola già cosa vuol dire questo
termine è utile per capirlo confrontarlo
con la conoscenza dei libri che è
conoscenza statica e che ha bisogno di
persone
che la mettano in azione la conoscenza
delle macchine digitali invece e
conoscenza che può andare in azione
appunto automaticamente e può produrre
nuova conoscenza quindi abbiamo un
automazione che agisce su un piano
estremamente diverso una donazione che
agisce sul piano cognitivo e questa è
davvero una rivoluzione perché riusciamo
non soltanto elaborare dati molto più
velocemente ma produciamo anche nuova
conoscenza
c'è però un elemento importante che va
sottolineato come avviene questa
elaborazione di conoscenza
le macchine digitali elaborano
rappresentazioni di concetti e lavorano
segni ma questi segni che vengono
elaborati hanno un significato per
l'essere umano per le persone
all'interno di convenzioni sociali
condivise per esempio la sequenza di
caratteri camera viene interpretata da
persone che parlano la lingua italiana
come camera da letto o camera da pranzo
insomma una stanza per le persone di
lingua inglese camera invece evoca un
significato di fotocamera o videocamera
quindi la stessa sequenza di caratteri
lo stesso segno la stessa
rappresentazione ha un significato
diverso
questa connessione tra segno e
significato è qualcosa che le macchine
non riescono a fare perché non hanno la
consapevolezza del significato e quindi
abbiamo questa rivoluzione che è
costituita dall avere delle macchine che
io chiamo macchine cognitive perché
fanno delle cose che fino a questo
momento solo gli esseri umani avevano
fatto sul piano cognitivo è però non
sono delle persone questa diciamo è una
rivoluzione anche dal punto di vista
sociale perché in un certo senso le
macchine che erano sempre state sotto il
dominio dell'essere umano si alzano
arrivano al livello dell'essere umano
arrivano quasi al livello delle persone
e quindi qui viene fuori una domanda
cioè queste macchine possono essere
considerate delle persone allora se
penso a una persona
quindi a un individuo in carne e ossa
difficilmente riesco a pensare una
macchina quantomeno ovvero una macchina
poi solo cognitiva
ora è vero che le macchine cognitive
possono replicare delle funzioni
che appartengono alla persona che
appartengono all'uomo però mi chiedo
riescono a pensare come fa una persona
riescono a interpretare emotivamente
quello che le persone dicono e fanno io
vorrei fare anche delle riflessioni o
comunque su quelli che sono alcuni
paradossi poi della di questa società
digitale e che hanno a che fare con la
persona no quindi con con l'individuo il
primo è senza dubbio una
spersonalizzazione dell'individuo in
alcuni casi e in altri la
personalizzazione di non individui di
non persone faccio un esempio
spersonalizzazione dell'individuo
pensiamo all identità digitale noi
sappiamo che l'identità digitale è fatta
di i dati di informazioni che si
riferiscono in modo univoco a
l'individuo quindi lo definiscono lo
contraddistinguono e lo rappresentano
digitalmente quindi attraverso quelle
che sono le interazioni elettroniche
questa identità digitale che comunque
importante che in un certo senso viene
anche assimilata noah all'identità
personale perché poi definisce anche
alcune caratteristiche dell'individuo
ovviamente è però dei limiti rispetto a
quello che noi definiamo come identità
personale perché l'identità personale
ciò che contraddistingue l'essere umano
in quanto unico quindi con determinate
caratteristiche però la differenza
evidente nola l'identità digitale
e si ottiene l'identità personale si
costruisce quindi già questa è una prima
secondo me distinzione importante per
contraddistinguere proprio l'unicità e
la complessità dell'essere umano
altro aspetto di paradosso e forse
questa personalizzazione invece delle
non persone faccio un esempio mi
riferisco ai bot di bot e come programmi
autonomi e quindi come software che in
qualche modo vengono addestrati diciamo
ad interagire a comportarsi come le
persone e tanto è vero che sono sempre
più perfezionati attraverso il machine
learning e quindi in qualche modo
interagiscono con le persone addirittura
le persone pensano di stare a parlare o
di interagire con essere umano invece
sono dei bot e quindi questo significa
in qualche modo non stiamo come dire
personalizzando ciò che non è
personalizzabile o comunque ciò che non
è un individuo che ecco anche questo è
un aspetto importante
faccio un po la coscienza critica e in
questo in questo senso aggiungo anche
uno stereotipo no un po della di questa
visione idealistica dell'innovazione
digitale che è importante ma che in
qualche modo dovrebbe migliorare tutti
gli aspetti della nostra vita
sicuramente un elemento positivo è
sicuramente migliorerà e migliora sta
migliorando quelli che sono molti
aspetti della nostra vita
però noi dobbiamo pensare anche in
termini di vantaggi ma di rischi o
comunque di limitazioni penso ad esempio
la sistemi di intelligenza artificiale e
alla limitazione della nostra libertà di
scelta perché adesso l'intelligenza
artificiale può anche prendere decisioni
al posto delle persone penso anche
all'europa ea tutte le attività che sta
facendo proprio per regolamentare
l'intelligenza artificiale e quindi
porre delle regole quindi proprio per
sugli aspetti etici e sugli aspetti
sociali della
derivanti proprio dall'intelligence
delle applicazioni dell'intelligenza
artificiale
la proposta adesso presentata anche che
si sta discutendo va proprio anche verso
una visione umano centrica quindi
l'importanza dell'essere umano che
rimane centrale quindi in tutta la
discussione che comunque deve essere
sempre presente e quindi controllare
quelle che sono queste applicazioni
quindi una visione umano centrica e che
fa ben sperare su quei principi anche
dell'umanesimo digitale quando per
esempio si dice che le tecnologie devono
essere progettate per i bisogni
dell'uomo e quindi non plasmare l'uomo
quindi questo è un principio ovviamente
importante no che è tra le basi
dell'umanesimo digitale proprio su
questo magari enrico dopo dire qualcosa
visto che sei stato anche uno degli
autori del manifesto di vienna del 2019
proprio sull'umanesimo digitale a maggio
del 2019 con alcuni colleghi di tutto il
mondo a vienna abbiamo lavorato questo
manifesto per l'umanesimo digitale
proprio sulla base dell'osservazione che
queste macchine cognitive che comunque
ci fanno fare delle cose meglio però
rischiano anche di disumanizzare le
persone this personalizzarle e di
soggiogarli di renderle schiave questo
deriva da due aspetti fondamentali due
caratteristiche fondamentali delle
macchine cognitive
la prima è che queste macchine non hanno
né la flessibilità nel adattabilità
degli esseri umani non sono flessibili
nell'imparare qualunque cosa nuova non
conoscono le macchine digitali possono
apprendere qualche cosa di nuovo ci sono
queste tecniche cosiddetti in inglese di
machine learning ovvero di apprendimento
automatico che rendono possibile
imparare dei comportamenti nuovi
all'interno però di scenari che in
qualche modo sono stati previsti
sappiamo invece che un essere umano un
bambino è in grado di imparare quasi
qualunque cosa nel mondo intorno intorno
a lui
non hanno adattabilità le macchine
cognitive non si trovano di fronte a
situazioni impreviste sono smarrite se
il progettista non ha pensato agli
scenari agli eventi che possano accadere
in questi scenari le macchine non sanno
le macchine digitali le macchine
cognitive non sanno come comportarsi per
questo non possiamo lasciarle operare da
sole in modo completamente autonomo ma
devono essere sempre in qualche modo
sotto la guida delle delle persone
quindi mancanza di flessibilità di età
disabilità è un primo elemento
importante l'altro è che queste macchine
non hanno nessuna consapevolezza di cosa
significhi essere umano essere una
persona sono disincarnate ora questo
qualcuno lo ritiene un vantaggio perché
dice così le macchine sono oggettive
nelle loro decisioni
in realtà non è così chi pensa che la
decisione algoritmica sia la migliore
decisione possibile o è un illuso oppure
d'alta un secondo interesse perchè chi
governa i fili di questi algoritmi e
quindi vuole convincere le persone che
va tutto bene
in realtà diciamo da che l'umanità ha
posseduto il linguaggio i conflitti sono
sempre esistiti ed è sempre stato
compito della politica decidere come
risolvere questi conflitti mediare tra
diversi interessi che sussistono sempre
in ogni gruppo di esseri umani
quindi l'unica intelligenza che può
prendere a ragion veduta delle decisioni
ben fatte su problemi che riguardano gli
esseri umani e l'intelligenza incarnata
delle persone non l'intelligenza
incorporea di queste macchine cognitive
per questo è uno dei punti centrali
appunto del manifesto diviene salutiamo
un appello a far sì che tutte le
decisioni che riguardino le persone e le
relazioni tra persone in ultima analisi
vengano sempre prese da altri esseri
umani e non da macchine proprio perché è
questo l'unico modo di poter decidere
nell'interesse degli esseri umani
le macchine cognitive elaborano le
rappresentazioni senza alcuna
consapevolezza di cosa stanno facendo e
del significato di quello che stanno
facendo
e lo fanno senza avere un corpo per
questo non sono nella posizione migliore
per poter giudicare
viceversa gli esseri umani essendo
intelligenza all'interno di un corpo un
corpo che è in grado di provare emozioni
sono in grado di prendere queste
decisioni nel modo migliore possibile
per questo nel manifesto di vienna
abbiamo ricordato alcuni aspetti
fondamentali il fatto che le decisioni
sulle persone devono essere sempre prese
da altri esseri umani
l'importanza del rispettare la privacy
l'importanza di rispettare la libertà di
espressione
il tener presente la diversità il tener
presente l'inclusione tutti i valori che
sono tipicamente umani e che devono
essere riportati a guidare lo sviluppo
digitale e sono tutti i valori che le
macchine non possono comprendere perché
non hanno la consapevolezza di cosa vuol
dire esseri umani e il punto è come
facciamo a educare le persone alla
comprensione di questi aspetti è
fondamentale lavorare proprio
sull'istruzione e non soltanto sulla
parte tecnica ovvero bisogna sapere come
sono fatte dal punto di vista tecnico
tecnologico queste macchine insomma sono
un informatico e quindi è importante
formare sull'informatica ma è importante
anche formare sulle conseguenze che le
tecnologie digitali hanno sulla società
e importante quindi una formazione
multidisciplinare una formazione in cui
a fianco della competenza tecnica venga
sviluppata una conoscenza degli aspetti
più umani degli aspetti etici degli
aspetti sociali degli aspetti che
appunto riguardano le persone e le
relazioni tra le persone e quindi la
domanda è come facciamo a elaborare e
come facciamo a pianificare a
programmare a mettere in gioco una
formazione di questo genere questo mi
sembra
diciamo una domanda su cui sabella può
darci degli spunti di riflessione penso
che la parola chiave sia a educare
perché questa è la parola chiave si lega
bene al concetto di consapevolezza
digitale chiaro
se vogliamo preparare i cittadini
competenti e consapevoli novi quello che
la società digitale dobbiamo partire dal
mondo della scuola e quindi insegnare
non soltanto quelli che sono i principi
base dell'informatica che costituiscono
il nucleo di questa società digitale ma
poi bisogna andare anche sugli aspetti
culturali in questo senso il progetto
che stiamo portando avanti che si chiama
programma il futuro va proprio in questa
direzione un progetto che nasce nel 2014
dal ministero dell'istruzione e
realizzato dal cini dal laboratorio
informatiche scuola del cini quindi
proprio per sviluppare sia la diffusione
della cultura informatica nella scuola
ma poi ampliando a questi aspetti di
cittadinanza digitale consapevole quindi
significa in qualche modo far ragionare
i ragazzi e ragazze sugli aspetti sui
meccanismi di questa società digitale e
quindi far in qualche modo sviluppare
anche un atteggiamento critico ma non di
rifiuto dell'innovazione è più che altro
un atteggiamento costruttivo propositivo
proattivo che li porti a considerare
tutti gli aspetti di vantaggio ma nello
stesso tempo anche quelle che sono
appunto le implicazioni di carattere
sociale
e importante infatti che si abbia la
costruzione come dire di un consumatore
attivo di queste tecnologie digitali e
nonni un consumatore passivo la
consapevolezza degli strumenti digitali
di come funziona la società digitale è
una forma di libertà perché la
conoscenza e libertà e quindi qui ci
ricolleghiamo no tutto il tema
ovviamente della democrazia digitale
quindi riprendo anche
lo spunto dal titolo un po che
abbiamo scelto per questo nostro
intervento che quello la democrazia non
è roba per macchine quindi enrico perché
la democrazia non è roba per macchine
perché abbiamo deciso di dare questo
messaggio perché abbiamo visto che nella
società digitale c'è una straordinaria
quantità di macchine le macchine
cognitive che fanno delle cose che
sembrano simulare il comportamento degli
esseri umani ma non sono persone
ora la democrazia è un pilastro
fondamentale della società moderna però
ha bisogno di persone in carne ed ossa
persone che abbiano una piena
consapevolezza di cosa vuol dire avere
un intelligenza in un corpo in grado di
provare emozioni
per questo la democrazia non è roba per
macchine